we begin with a dangerous trauma on a
mountain more than 10,000 feet above the
Pacific Northwest a climber was killed
yesterday after falling hundreds of feet
down Mount Hood the rescue effort -
saved six others stranded with rocks and
ice falling around them stretched well
into the night the two groups of
climbers were stuck in the hogsback area
near the summit it took more than eight
hours for the last climber to be brought
to safety at Mount Hood's Timberline
Lodge and that's where Jamie yuccas is
Jamie good morning good morning it's
these snowy and wet conditions that came
in overnight that have rescuers racing
to get those climbers off the mountain
but yesterday was unseasonally warm and
rescuers say it's that melt and thaw
that can make climbing especially
dangerous this was the scene after one
unidentified climber slid some 700 feet
down the face of Mount Hood Tuesday
morning he was just coming down the
mountain and some snow or ice broke
loose under his feet and he started to
fall he was able to use his axe to slow
his fall for about a hundred feet and
then after that he just lost his hold
and fell another however many five six
hundred feet the climber was airlifted
by a Blackhawk helicopter to a Medical
Center where he was declared dead he was
part of a team of four climbers they
were stranded in a climbing route known
as hogsback
more than ten thousand feet up the
mountain a crew of at least 40 assisted
in the rescue effort one says with the
falling rock and ice it felt like being
in a bowling alley the conditions up
there are bad for hikers climbers and
and quite frankly for the rescuers as
well it took eight hours for rescuers to
bring two other men in the group to
safety the fourth climber was rescued by
sled authorities say she suffered no
severe physical injuries but was
apparently too distraught by her
teammates death to climb down unassisted
she was later able to walk off this
rescue vehicle on her own so you said
the one woman was very shaken up
absolutely yeah from what I understand
like that was kind of our climbing
mentor so they had done a lot of
climbing together so very
their personal situation for her another
group of three hikers also had to be
rescued they all made it to safety and
none of them had serious injuries the
Oregon newspaper says ten thousand
hikers a year go up Mount Hood a hundred
people have died and just in 2017 four
people died Gale thank you very much
Jamie